all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Defenders
Beyond and the ending of the story is
nuts oh my God it's so good the story
itself is amazing it's just ridiculously
awesome but what this does here is this
basically picks up with one of the
beyonders and I say that because we're
gonna see more but it picks up with one
of the beyonders and kind of the main
beyonder basically talking to the
Defenders and kind of giving us a sort
of new origin for everything now what Al
Ewing does here is he Blends the origin
of all things in existence from his
ultimate's run with the beyonders
themselves so for those of you guys who
saw our videos on Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers oh my God that
story or you saw our videos on Al
Ewing's ultimates bear with me here
because we're going to kind of bring
this together for people who haven't so
the idea behind this is what the
beyonder says in the beginning there was
the first firmament now the way this
origin worked in Al yuang's ultimates
and he really again is kind of carrying
it over here the first firmament was
basically created by the one above all
that's the only real indication that we
ever get when it comes to its existence
but the idea is the first firmament was
basically the only thing in existence
you can call it a universe if you want
to and what the first firmament did is
it created a group of beings that were
called the aspirins and these aspirins
were monochrome in nature right they
were black and white and that was it the
idea behind this is that the aspirants
traveled around the universe they
created galaxies Stars solar systems
planets life all that kind of stuff but
whenever they created anything they went
to the first firmament and they sought
its approval if the first firmament
hated what the aspirants had done then
the aspirants would destroy their
creation and they would start over if
the first firmament approved of the
creation the net creation would continue
on but there was a subset of the
aspirants who actually disagreed with
the idea of seeking approval for their
creations and believe that things should
change and evolve and grow and so what
this subsect did is it gave themselves
colors in a different form and started
calling themselves the celestials and
then ultimately a holy war broke out a
war between those who were faithful to
the to the first tournament and those
who were not these celestials ultimately
won but in doing so shattered the first
firmament into an infinite number of
pieces and that's where the first
Multiverse comes from and so when that
happened the birth of the first
Multiverse led to an infinite number of
possibilities and that's why as the
beyonder explains this he says that what
we got was a Multiverse of possibility
where each what if would become its own
what is because prior to the Multiverse
it was just what if this happened what
if that happened and you would never
find out but when the Multiverse came
into existence it was what if this
happened and then that what if became
its own universe meaning it became what
is and so as time progressed this is
where the origin of the beyonders comes
into play and it's a part that might
prove to be a little controversial
because of the fact that a holy war did
break out between the aspirants and the
celestials in order to prevent a holy
war like that happening again seemingly
the end of all things the celestials
created the beyonder and the idea was
that the honors were created with such a
level of power they could destroy the
celestials if they needed to hence the
reason why they were a Fail-Safe it
wouldn't make any sense for the
celestials to create a group of beings
that could prevent any kind of a
Celestial war from happening if those
beings were incapable of destroying
celestials and so ultimately what ended
up happening is when the beyonders were
created by the celestials they literally
just existed out there right in the
Beyond verse as just kind of a thing
where it was like a Fail-Safe right if
things pop off between the celestials a
great big huge War takes place and all
things could be jeopardized the
beyonders could step in they could
annihilate those celestials recreate
them and then leave again right that's
literally all it would be the kicker
about all this and what's so interesting
is you literally have the question
that's asked by Blue Marvel in them
right like they're kind of like okay so
how do you reconcile basically the
destruction of the seventh Cosmos I.E
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and Secret Wars in 2015 but
before we get to that answer one of the
things that's really kind of asked here
is this beyonder they're talking to is
it the same beyonder from the original
Secret Wars in 1984 and the response to
this beyonder is yes I am definitively
that beyonder but I'm the more adult
version now here's where things get
interesting right and here's where we
kind of bring in Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers and reconcile those things
so when Jonathan Hickman wrote Avengers
and New Avengers and he introduced the
ivory Kings the beyonders whatever you
want to call him right the white Lords
of wild space which I still say is one
of the coolest names for the beyonders
in the history of Marvel Comics when
that whole thing happened what we didn't
know was how you reconcile the beyonders
with the beyonder that we saw before and
while Hickman did that in a pretty
significant way or pretty basic way like
literally it was Black Panther analyzing
it and saying that version of the
beyonder was a child unit or at least I
think it was Hing Pym who said it maybe
the important thing is he didn't really
go that far in reconciling them what Al
Ewing does here is he says okay so when
it comes to this original beyonder that
when the molecule man Owen Reese first
gained his powers he did so by basically
puncturing a hole into the Beyond verse
without realizing it he was basically
creating a Cosmic Cube and didn't know
it and so we're half that power went
into the molecule man the other half of
that power was basically the beyonder
which was still in an infant state but
because that hole was punched that hole
remained which meant that this baby
beyonder if you want to call it that
looked through that hole and saw the
entirety of the Marvel Multiverse on the
other side and was exceedingly curious
about it and that's why the beyonder did
what it did during Secret Wars in 1984
and that's why that beyonder seems brand
new it doesn't understand superheroes
it's easily manipulated by Dr Doom
different things along those lines right
it's more curious about superheroes than
anything else why do good guys fight bad
guys why do good guys fight good guys
right why do things like that happen the
reason why this beyonder looks the way
it does right now with like the great
big huge silver shoulder straps and all
that kind of stuff is because that's the
the last form that it took before we
basically saw its non-existence right
before it seemingly ceased to exist when
we saw it in secret Wars 2 and then the
unofficial Fantastic Four Secret Wars
follow-up which basically saw the
beyonder and molecule man merging into a
Cosmic Cube together by and large Al
Ewing is ignoring that Fantastic Four
story so we can also ignore it as well
but basically this form that we see with
the beyonder is the last time we saw it
in terms of his physical appearance and
so it's kind of cool here because one of
the things that the beyonders say here
is that in this place where the
Defenders are at they're beyond the
Multiverse and the reality is they
cannot observe the beyonders in their
most pure form so that's why the
beyonders took on a physical form made
of matter in order to communicate with
them it's not that dissimilar from what
the cosmic entities do what the cosmic
entities do is they go to a realm called
the dimension of manifestations and they
meet with a being called anthropomorpho
and anthropomorpho gives them a physical
form that their quote-unquote concept
can house and then they appear in the
main Marvel Universe it's just one of
those things that takes place that was
established back in the old Quasar
comics in the Eur early 1990s but the
thing about this is that's why the
beyonders appear the way they do is
because it's really the only way that
these guys could understand them and so
following back to our question where
they ask about Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers the collapse
of the Multiverse the grand experiment
is that in that story what Jonathan
Hickman had established is that the
origin of molecule man Owen Reese is
exact across every Universe it's the
exact same origin and the reason for
that is because what the beyonders
wanted to do is they wanted to basically
ensure that someone like the molecule
man could basically house an
astronomical amount of power because
remember Owen Reese was powerful enough
where he was powerful on a multiversal
level he was astronomically powerful but
when he dies right when he is destroyed
he wipes out a whole universe in the
process the idea of the beyonders was to
detonate the molecule man Owen Reese
across every single universe and blow up
every universe and destroy the
Multiverse in the process at the time
that Jonathan Hickman wrote that story
it was just an experiment and that was
it what Al Ewing establishes here is
that there was actually a motivation
behind it that the reality and it's not
really overly explained here it's just
kind of a more of a hand wavy thing than
anything else but what the be honors
were doing is what was basically called
a controlled demolition like when a city
destroys a building it was literally one
of those things where they were like it
was time for the seventh Cosmos to end
right we had to end it so that we could
basically stop some major coming threat
called the Dominion and we don't exactly
know what it is but it's just some major
threat that exists out there that's
going to arrive and when it does
basically everything's going to be
destroyed the hopes of the beyonders was
to basically keep that threat from
coming at Bay by destroying the seventh
Cosmos but as we know while the seventh
Cosmos was destroyed right the
Multiverse did die Doctor Doom sees the
Power of the beyonders for himself he
brought everything back or most
everything back in the form of battle
world and then at the end of Secret Wars
the power of the beyonders was taken
from Dr Doom by the molecule man given
to Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
and Reed Richards said everything back
that by and large what it basically
meant is everything was effectively
reset to the way it was before the
events of Avengers The New Avengers ever
happened meaning the threat of the
Dominion remains it was never stopped
and so as a result of that while this is
a kind of New Concept we didn't know
about the Dominion before then
ultimately the superheroes literally
secured their own demise and so at the
moment the beyonders are actually trying
to figure out a way to stop the Dominion
from appearing because they know if they
were to try to initiate some major
multiversal cataclysm like they did
before then ultimately there'd be no way
of stopping it the superheroes would
ultimately prevent it from happening
right Secret Wars would happen all over
again and so one of the crazy things
that goes on is that you do have this
bit of a discussion and for the
beyonders themselves they appear very
human in nature right in terms of how
they communicate how they talk how they
act because it's a way that human beings
would be able to identify with that the
thing about this is the beyonders intend
to destroy the Defenders because if the
Defenders travel further it could
complicate whatever plans the beyonders
have now the reason why the beyonders
want to even destroy the defenders in
the first place beyond complicating
their plans is they know the Defenders
will try to push further beyond the
Beyond verse which is really kind of an
interesting theme because in Marvel
Comics there was no indication that
there was anything beyond the Beyond
verse outside of like the far short
right where like Cosmic entities go to
die that was it right the far Shore is
as close as you get to the realm of the
one above all and even depending on
who's telling the story it in fact is
the realm of the one above all right it
really just kind of depends on what's
going on but the thing about this is
that the Defenders will try to push
further they'll try to go beyond and as
a result of that the beyonder is trying
to destroy them right now will basically
keep that from happening and so blue
Marvel gives America Chavez The Eternity
mask because remember the eternity mask
is basically a plot device right it's
just a giant McGuffin it'll allow who's
ever whoever's wearing it to have power
on par with whoever they're fighting
what this establishes is that there's no
limit to the level of power that the
eternity mask can copy be because you
literally have America Chavez who gets
into a hand-to-hand fight with the
beyonder itself but while she's dealing
with the main beyonder you in turn have
the other beyonders that try to destroy
the Defenders now the cool thing about
this and kind of a caveat here is
remember Loki is now the god of stories
which means that Loki controls the
narrative it's basically a meditable way
of Al Ewing saying like Loki controls
what happens in a story so it's really
kind of a weird thing because at this
point Loki's like you're now confined to
the stories that I create and if the
story that I create says we as the
Defenders will find a way to destroy you
then that means we as the Defenders will
find a way to destroy you right like
that's going to happen there's no
conceivable way to stop it it's simply
just a matter of time now there it's
kind of one of those open-ended things
where maybe the Defenders like die here
they come back at some future point in
time and they destroy the beyonders then
we don't really know like it's just one
of those things where their defeat is
governed so literally everything that
you see transpiring from this point
going forward is being done so based on
the story narrative that Loki has
created I know it's kind of weird it's a
little wonky Al Ewing can be a little
zany with how he writes his stories the
content in the stories is amazing but
the way he tells them is a little weird
right if you don't believe me look no
further than the immortal Hulk
because literally at the end of that
story we find out what happens when the
one above all hulks out and basically he
becomes the one below all and is kind of
nuts but as this beyonder is trying to
destroy the different members of The
Defenders blue Marvel basically charges
up and destroys this beyonder himself
right literally blue Marvel kills a
beyonder now he does but he doesn't
right like he basically destroys the
physical form of the beyonder but the
reality here is that these guys are
living raw power right just Raw Creation
in its most pure form they cannot be
truly annihilated and destroyed they
could only ever be destroyed in the
moment right temporarily that's all they
can ever really do but because it is a
body made of matter and and blue Marvel
is a living antimatter reactor it's
literally just a knife punching holes
and cheese that's all it is right just
it's a hot knife through butter so he
just destroys this physical form of the
beyonder and that's basically it now
eventually it does reconstitute itself
but they also realize that there's
basically a portal that the honors have
that will allow the Defenders to
transport Beyond right to move Beyond
and so literally The Defenders end up
traveling through this portal and then
the the kind of main beyonder from
Secret Wars follows them and what they
end up doing and it's really one of
these one of these crazy things the
beyonders ask the question the broken
one gives Chase right the broken
beyonder is what they what they call him
and they ask should we prevent this and
the statements made don't succumb to
narrative forces we have done all we can
if the Defenders choose to Traverse
beyond the Beyond they have chosen the
path of trial they have chosen fire and
so what we're literally told here is
fire and Limitless light yawning wide
for eternity's Defenders as Taya opens
herself up for the white hot heart that
turns a cosmos and speaks life at the
edge of life's end and so she's met by
this kind of disembodied voice and it
seemingly takes her over right literally
it says you called out in defiance of
death I heard and I came now anybody
who's familiar with Marvel Comics
anybody who knows who knows anything
about Marvel Comics in relation to Chris
claremont's run of the X-Men you know
exactly who this is because you've seen
this statement before you've read this
statement before where a person was
dying and their mind called out in
defiance of death for some some form of
Aid and a figure appeared that saved
them and everybody else they knew from
death and so suddenly you have this
figure who appears to The Defenders and
says Defenders hear me no longer am I
the science ear that you knew I am tired
no more I am Fire and Life incarnate now
and forever I am the Phoenix quite
literally The Defenders have traveled to
the white hot room now for those of you
guys who don't know who what the white
hot room is you'll find out next week
because we're gonna bring this video to
an
endanger thank you guys for watching and
I will catch you all later oh here's a
question you have to ask what happens
now that you have a a beyonder in the
white hot room is the Phoenix more
powerful than the beyonder that's the
question you got to ask but thank you
all for watching and I will catch you on
later peace